yeah what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
you might have seen earlier today I
tweeted Apple released this adventure
video with the rock featuring Siri so
naturally that got me to click it I mean
it's a movie featuring Siri what could
possibly go wrong so I clicked that I
watched it and it was actually pretty
well done it was interesting I'll link
it below if you want to watch the whole
thing and of course it also got me
thinking Siri did a lot in that video
and it made me wonder if Siri can
actually do all of the things that the
rock asked it to do in that adventure so
iOS 11 latest update build number three
I've decided to see if this can actually
do everything the bass of it I also
realize that's probably exactly what
Apple wants you to do after watching
this because it's basically an ad for
Siri but hey what act let's try it hey
Siri read my schedule
you have 25 appointments at 7:15 hey
Siri read my schedule there's nothing
okay so I don't use Apple calendar quite
as much as apparently the rock does but
if I did they would all show up there
just like that hey Siri show me my life
goals list I found 10 reminders hey Siri
show me my life goals list I found five
reminders okay so this shows reminders
specifically from Apple's reminders app
so if you use the reminders app and you
go in and you create a new list with a
certain name then Siri can recall
anything from that list and show it to
you at any time so yeah I made one
called life goals and I asked it to show
it and it worked
hey Siri give me a lift ride to LAX we
can get you a lift in 60 seconds okay so
I don't have lift but I you can get it
to do the exact same thing with the uber
app this is actually one of the more
recent improvements to Siri actually
reaching inside supported apps and
taking action within them yes what's the
temperature in Rome today
the high temperature for today in Rome
will be 80 degrees and the low will be
59 degrees this one's pretty
straightforward weather card is like the
standard demo question of course that
works also the rock you're literally
hijacking a plane at this point during
your adventure so maybe reconsider maybe
put like a disclaimer like don't try
this at home or something like that hey
Siri read me my last email at 9:30 a.m.
this one sent you an email about mr.
Nakamura can discuss your fashion line
so this Siri command will not work for
you if you use Gmail or a yahoo mail or
any other mail service or third-party
app or anything like that you have to
use Apple Mail if you do then it will
work apparently the rock also uses Apple
Mail hey Siri show me photos of my
fashion line it okasada
what do you think it doesn't really
matter what I think do you think so if I
ask Siri for pictures of something it's
just gonna google it that actually it
bings it it Bing searches for your
photos but if I say show me photos of my
fashion line it just shows the first
Bing search results for my fashion line
which is just random clothes but when
the rock shows the phone to mr. whatever
his name was it clearly is not Syria
anymore is this all white background so
that looks like it's in his gallery if
he did all that with Syria he'd have to
say something like show me my photos of
clothes or something like that to
trigger shiri to open the gallery so the
language he uses in that clip isn't
quite Siri text Chef Ludo I want to cook
hey Siri text Wayne nice commercial bro
yes so yes you can send text messages
with Siri but also not shown as you do
have to do a follow-up to make sure you
actually want to send it hey Siri how
many ounces in a centimeter one
centiliter is 0.34 fluid ounces it's
also good movie joke ok first time I
heard this I thought he was asking how
many ounces in a centimeter which
obviously that's not a thing but what
he's asking is how many ounces in a
centimeter that's a pretty standard
conversion question Siri handles that
just fine no problem
hey see
we play my practice playlist so this
again only works with Apple music so you
can have all the Spotify and SoundCloud
and title playlists you want but if you
ask Siri to play music it will look in
Apple music so technically this is
possible again assuming the rock uses
Apple music along with all the rest of
those Apple services Siri take a selfie
open up cars on Eclipse so this command
actually triggers Siri opening the
front-facing camera which is pretty cool
but it doesn't actually press the
shutter button and take a selfie though
that actually has to be done with the
on-screen button which is impossible
when you're in space wearing gloves or
I'm assuming what he does here is
squeeze the volume button to trigger the
shutter and that actually does take a
picture the bigger problem is the
caseless iPhone in space but overall at
the end of the day series scored pretty
well actually against its ad and at the
end of the day that's exactly what that
is this is a serie a die think the main
takeaway here is it's pretty similar to
those shot on iphone commercials
technically yes most of this will work
but that sequences shortened little
blurb at the end is pretty important
pretty much everything in the commercial
happens instantly in real life with Siri
even on the latest version of iOS 11
you're gonna have to wait a little bit
and you're also gonna have to use pretty
much all Apple services for Siri to talk
to it but for the most part it works I
think people might be surprised how much
better Sirius gotten in the past couple
months I'm looking forward to comparing
it again with like pretty much the rest
of voice assistance Google assistant in
its latest form maybe Alexa maybe throw
in Bixby voice for fun that could be its
own separate video in the meantime
though that's pretty much it thank you
for watching the ROK if you're watching
this if you're one of those people
watching I heard you have a YouTube
channel now that's pretty cool maybe if
you want to collab on some tech related
stuff that could be fun just let me know
hit me up on FaceTime that's pretty much
it talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]
hey Siri seriously I want your best joke
the past present and future walk into
the bar it was tense